you have to see it on a big screen
because there's so much happening in the
frame yeah at every single moment you
could look anywhere and you're seeing a
whole you know this whole tapestry of
Madness was it a deep tissue massage you
were having where are you going with the
screen
weren't you having a Turkish massage or
something I don't know what it has to do
with what we're talking about it's a
funny story tell it
I had an awful experience having a
Turkish massage
where
this guy's idea of massage was to like
take my one leg and and the other arm
and try and connect it
behind my back
and I was kind of like
you know like that and then I
well his belly went in my mouth
it was like a little borax
and you know when you get something
weird in your mouth and you're like if
you're eating something you go like you
said your brain sends your tongue to
figure out what it is
conscious thought it's just like is that
a bone figure that out the time goes in
to figure it out my tongue was like what
is that
it's a hairy belly
this sounds like you're heading off a
newspaper
like Dame Julie Andrews you now have two
Grammys
[Applause]
you perform them did you before them I
did yeah so what is that I mean that
must be so stressful to be up for awards
and having to perform and it's all live
terrifying yeah honestly
um and I only found out I was going to
perform in the Grammys a week before the
Grammys oh my gosh so I was like oh my
God what am I gonna I literally didn't
have time to think about anything I was
just like okay I'm going on the Grammys
don't mess this up so where's the Grammy
now oh yes good question it's at home
um in the Attic no
that's true no it's it's in my living
room nice oh good but both of them right
yes yes you've got both I do are they
beside each other are they nice are they
booking
they'll be lonely otherwise they won't
be really late what one Grammy
great characters on Saturday Night Live
you're Justin Bieber Justin Bieber is
spookly accurate
that is incredible yeah thank you you've
done it in front of him haven't you I
have not you haven't
reached
I met him before because he hosted SNL
once and then uh that was before I
started doing an impression of him but I
was so struck by how this was before he
got really beefy for those Calvin
kleinance and now he looks like you know
a big Beefcake but
um he was really he was very delicately
very tender beautiful just such a
beautiful face and such a big big hat
such big clothes and just the most
beautiful and I I am a huge fan of his
and I love it now you have a special way
of a special way of preparing the face
haven't you yes
um yes you you want to look as though
you've done something wrong but like
hahaha
[Music]
all right very good
hey ladies and gentlemen before we do
another thing yeah is there a doctor in
the house why yes there is uh Dr Will
Ferrell wow
since you were last here yes who made
you a doctor
um uh the University of Southern
California okay which is my university
in Los Angeles and I received an
honorary doctorate they say it's
honorary I think it's for real
I've performed 13 successful surgeries
and a hundred that didn't go so well
so I'm currently I have a lot of
malpractice issues yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah but at these things you have to
make the kind of the inspirational
speech so what did you tell the young
people I um yeah it I hadn't been put in
that position before because usually I
just make fun of things right and and
that's uh that's easy but then you have
to be Earnest and uh yeah that was that
was a difficult task uh so I I just told
them to uh keep your feet firmly planted
on the ground and reach for the stars
which I read on the back of a cereal box
I just took a very unexpected turn I
feel uh at the end yes yes no I I
thought I would Inspire the graduating
class by uh singing a Whitney Houston
song today
which one did you choose will the theme
from The Bodyguard yes I will always
love you yeah I will always that's
lovely yes yeah and now apparently you
sang the whole thing
I started thinking do I just sing a
couple of lines or do I torture the
students and their parents by singing
the entire song and I chose the ladder
yeah he's not joking we have a little
flip this is a tiny clip if you actually
can I just say you're rather good
[Music]
s
did you see me look down to try to
remember the words
love you
how did you cope and keeping that thing
on your breasts oh yeah that's what I
think I'm watching then going is that
going to stay on I mean that's what that
is
there was a lot of yeah slips but that I
am like even in that scarf thing that
we're calling a dress I am still
probably the most clothed person
so honestly I but we were also
desensitized to nudity very quickly in
real life how long were you at that
party for oh that's you crowd surfing
that is it was yeah it was me crowds of
you okay so fun so we get why it's
called Babylon now right clearly this is
like the G-rated version of that part I
mean the party is insane Damien I mean
such a Visionary kind of director but
there's an amazing extraordinary one in
that party scene where you kind of meet
all the different characters and it's a
huge ensemble cast you've got Brad Pitt
and Diego and you know Gene Smart and
you've got a chicken stealing someone's
cocaine and running up you know like
stunts you've got someone falling from
the ceiling so this is all being timed
with like this crane movement we're not
shooting in studio we're shooting like
on location so it's even more difficult
but so much is happening
um and and you kind of get a glimpse of
everything it's the kind of movie where
you have to see it on a big screen
because there's so much happening in the
frame yeah at every single moment you
could look anywhere and you're seeing a
whole you know this whole tapestry of
Madness
um but doing those one is and knowing
that you don't want to be the person
that makes you go again um
romantic gestures you I mean you were
obviously very young no you loved a boy
yes and he lives in Cork was it yes he
did live in Cork I'm mortified because
he's going to know exactly who I'm
talking about I was only 5 please keep
that in mind when I continue the story I
don't I was really in love with him and
I thought for some reason the most
romantic thing I could do was to send
him some of my teeth
you'll never look at me the same
very romantic gesture very eye-catching
they'll never forget you for yourself
how old is he also five okay
you saw somebody kidnapped you and it
was a ransom note
please mommy help us save Nicola
the Tooth Fairy I think he couldn't tell
you it was just an intro I've mellowed
out since then
she started what's wrong
I clapped I clapped the Pearl out of my
ring but it looks like a tooth
okay
we're just gonna get that well I don't
even know
I'm not interested in love
feel a connection to Russia because you
are Russian properly Russian when I'm
half Russian my mum's London
um West Ham actually so I'm probably
West Ham as well
yeah
is
um so yeah my dad was born in Russia
yeah he came when he was two years old
grew up here but he was born in Russia
yeah because your name I mean you were
born with a proper Russian name which I
can't yes
well actually Helen but lyanna is of a
Russian version of that yeah and I've
heard you're talking about your
household that it was quite Russian
growing up like there wasn't apparently
Russian I didn't know this there's not
much Small Talk No you don't have small
talk in in a Russian now so what do you
talk about you talk about the soul and
you talk about you know is there God and
you talk about deep philosophical stuff
so when I sort of grew up and and left
home I found it almost impossible I
would find it impossible to sit here and
not talk about really heavy stuff we'll
get to that well we will yeah when I
hosted it it was a bit
[Laughter]
what a time to to be Kingsley benedir I
mean it's I mean just well done you it's
amazing it's all it's all happening so
you went from you know the classic kind
of you know working British actor you'd
a recurring role in Vera piggy blinders
yeah but you know and people do that but
there you've gone on to play these big
American icons uh you know Barack Obama
in the Comey Rule and then Malcolm X in
one night in Miami so I suppose for any
British actor watching this how does
that happen how do you how do you make
that did one person see you or did you
go out in America and just wait how did
it happen
I don't know I feel like the last few
months has been really trippy I feel I
feel like
you know shoot in Barack and working
with Regina it happened so suddenly it
was such a whirlwind and you know I had
just a couple of weeks to prepare and
someone had pulled out and
there wasn't really much time to sort of
like think about it it was just like
[__] you gotta crack on and dive in and
just get on with it it's only sort of as
the films
come out and we're in lockdown and you
know yeah
it's it's been it's it's been a bit
intense yeah yeah also like Americans
must be thinking it's so weird when they
see you on chat shows because they have
no idea that you're English well I've
never been on a tattoo this is the first
chapter uh
[Applause]
[Music]
okay this is weird Ricky John Page
played you on Saturday Night Live on
last Saturday and you have never been on
a show it was so trippy man someone
someone sent me a link to this thing I
woke up on Sunday morning and they were
like you've been mentioned on SNL and
then I clicked it and I was like
it's this guy from Bridgeton doing an
impression of me on like mainstream
American television and any and he
mentioned like I think he said like yeah
I'm from kentish town in it
that's obviously like what I sound like
but
um yeah I've been in Canada my whole
life oh wow so well uh Americans uh he's
British there you go yeah you know now
you know ladies and gentlemen
WWE Superstar John Cena
[Applause]
[Music]
that's my life in about 20 seconds
that's your intro song over the ring oh
yeah and and tens of thousands of people
will say John Cena sucks so every night
grow with a smile on my face told us so
you put your hand at a louder they get
oh man yeah yes
even in the reverse too if you act like
it doesn't get to you they know they're
getting matching yeah there's no way
around it doesn't everyone every
wrestler has a name yes and people think
that like hey man how'd you make up the
name John Cena
I was like no dude I would have made up
like dick hammerbush or something cool
like that
camera or something I don't know
let's move from there no one's letting
you go out with that
it seems like the business part of your
brain was developed quite young like you
were a little girl and you were quite
business savvy yes quite Savvy as a kid
I would like steal my brother's toys and
sell them on the side of the road for
like an extortionate prize I make up um
magic tricks and then make my family
pay to come see my magic show and then
pay extra if they wanted to know how I
did the trick
that's a really good idea all the time
you would pay extra to find out how they
do that yeah well once you get them in I
mean they're already there they already
paid their dollar sure yeah yeah because
now because Ryan you were also a young
entrepreneur weren't you
I wouldn't say that no
well didn't your father what did he eat
he wanted you to sell was it cellophane
you want to do so
my parents Came Upon a truck of
cellophane somehow
it's not to ask too many questions I
just suddenly there was a basement
filled with cellophane and uh
they encouraged me to go to school and
see if I could sell it to my teachers or
put a few in my backpack and try and
hock them at recess you know
convince kids that they might be good uh
stocking stuffers for their parents
of cellophane
how did it go
I know the name but I don't know what
you do with it you know you wrap
sandwiches in it it keeps things fresh
oh okay
I'm sorry no no it was an important
question yeah
I'm not doing a good job of selling it
obviously but did you did you sell it
there's still some left if you're
interested
I'd be nice to someone the dream was
someone would just say I'll take all of
it
never happened
[Music]